it's worth remembering this is a brand
new illness it transmits relatively
easily
and in some people of course it's severe
it's therefore important that we break
the transmission in society we do not
allow this virus to go from household to
household and that's what the social
distancing measures are about trying to
slow the rate of transmission in order
to know whether those measures are
working we track a number of things and
here you can see the transport use
change which we've shown before
indicating very substantial reductions
in the use of London Underground the bus
is national rail and indeed use of all
motor vehicles this and other measures
show that the contact between people has
reduced dramatically as a result of the
social distancing measures that have
been put in place that in turn should
lead to a substantial reduction in the
transmission of the virus in the
community this if I can have the next
slide please
moves then through into the fewer new
cases appearing is the aim to try and
reduce the number of new cases this
shows the number of cases since the 16th
of March through to the 7th of April and
what you can see is there is not that
big upswing of growth that we talked
about at the beginning there is a fairly
steady increase in numbers it's possible
that we're beginning to see the
beginning of change in terms of the
curve flattening a little bit we won't
know that for sure
for a week or so but what we're not
seeing is an acceleration it's important
that we keep these new cases down
because of course this in turn leads to
the number of people going into hospital
and the aim all along is to reduce the
number of cases below the capacity of
the NHS and to save lives can I have the
next slide please
this graph shows the number of hospital
admissions in London at the top and then
in other areas you can see again there's
been a steady increase since the 16th of
March up until the 7th of April
but there hasn't been the accelerated
takeoff and again it's possible that
we're beginning to see the start of a
change where we might see numbers
flattening off
we can't won't be sure about that for a
week or so and we need to keep looking
at it but it does begin to suggest that
things might be moving in the right
direction in terms of numbers and it's
important that we carry on with the
measures we've got in place in order to
make sure that this does go in the right
direction
the important thing beyond these numbers
is what happens in intensive care units
and that we keep the intensive care unit
number down as well and that's another
thing which may be moving in the right
direction but I do want to here say a
big thank you to everybody in the NHS
the frontline staff we were working so
hard to make this work